hey guys it's jake paul here coming at
you with a brand new epic games video
i'm about to box your grandma in the
ring madison square garden pay-per-view
on netflix going to flip reset on your
mom afterwards and get ssl before your
dad beats your ass with a belt for
crying on your fortnite themed ps5 after
you lose to me it's about to be awesome
guys okay hold on like i'm sorry i i
can't do this it's just so [ __ ]
cringe dude like why do you need an
intro for a video you saw the thumbnail
you probably read half the [ __ ] title
so you know what this video is about the
video is going to teach you how to be
the spawn devil from hell it's going to
teach you how to not only troll but turn
everyone around you into trolls too your
dog will be a troll it'll teach you the
ways of just being the worst piece of
garbage player rocket league has to
offer and it will teach you to blame
everyone else instead because nothing
can ever be your fault because you're
the god damn best player of all time it
doesn't matter that you're a true plat
your mindset is ssl so that means you
are ssl and everyone else is trash this
video will teach you how to be the worst
rocket league player ever
[Music]
so obviously we need to start with the
[ __ ] car now if you want to be a
sweaty poop stain you go hit ranked with
the stock tank no decal no antenna no
topper cristiano virgin wheels only no
outside you can never go outside outside
is the forbidden temple your outside is
manfield night now we also can't be
letting people know that we're highly
depressed individuals with the fetish
for suffering so we need to change our
name to something that shows how we feel
but do not explain why we feel this way
whatsoever so change that name to a
goddamn punctuation mark throw a comma
in there and if you want to get [ __ ]
serious make it a period because we
don't [ __ ] around and we mean business
now that profile picture it's looking
way too [ __ ] colorful dude we gotta
change that [ __ ] up make it just [ __ ]
black we don't need to show [ __ ] that we
like because we don't like anything the
only thing we like is licking the tears
of our enemies which is everybody in the
[ __ ] world after all that it's time
for a 45 minute slow mode free play
session once you're feeling unnaturally
speedy you're ready to hit the pitch but
before that you gotta decide what
playlist to play now you're a sweat lord
you're here to compete at the highest
level so you don't even think about
casual casual is for [ __ ] casuals for
beta males that don't hit the gym nine
times a week have 16 scoops of g fuel
running through your veins and hot spicy
explosive diarrhea coming out of your
[ __ ] you are here to farm mmr and
make kids cry to their mommies while
doing it just so their dad can beat him
with a belt again so casual is a no-go
zone [ __ ] that [ __ ] now extra modes you
know we [ __ ] with extra modes you know
why because we need to get those [ __ ]
titles [ __ ] snow day skyrim wizard
blizzard making a floor destroyer on
netflix receding hairline hoops laker
and rumble these balls in your mouth rng
champ we need these titles like we need
attention and trust me we crave [ __ ]
attention and if we're not getting
attention then we piss moan and wine in
the text chat until we do it's not like
we're gonna get attention from our
parents anyway you know what i'm saying
that that's what video games are for
okay now let's look at the normal modes
now you're probably a platinum 1b once
because you can't figure out what to do
when you can't blame your teammates
remember it can never be your [ __ ]
fault if you lose that's beta male [ __ ]
mindset if anyone asks why you're
plating 1v1s and champion 3s just say
you main twos in that your ssl but you'd
be [ __ ] justin if your teammates were
better so basically our only options are
twos and threes you can play either one
but if you choose threes you're gonna
need to go watch justin's season 5 goal
69 times in a row that [ __ ] will get the
blood pumping and in the right mindset
to lose in [ __ ] overtime anyway
now if you're thinking 2v2s you'll need
to go watch monkey videos on youtube for
at least a couple hours trust me there's
plenty of monkey gorilla ape content out
there for you to consume because guess
what [ __ ] we're going in the twos like
we're george of the [ __ ] jungle
looking for [ __ ] in the jungle and
[ __ ] because we're going to be swinging
all over the place not caring about what
[ __ ] anybody thinks we're chasing
baby buck rotation that [ __ ] is for
[ __ ] now you're ready to go and just
go out there and be the [ __ ] menace
that you were born to be go in angry
very angry right from the get-go if your
teammate does anything that you do not
like stop playing completely just give
the [ __ ] up and let them know that
you're upset by sitting there in
complete silence the game is [ __ ]
washed anyway any mistakes from others
should never be allowed or tolerated
because we don't make mistakes and
neither should anybody else in fact if
your teammate forfeits after [ __ ] up
so much don't forfeit yourself waste
their time like they wasted your mmr
it's their fault they're still trying
when your team is down one with four
minutes left it's over with no chance of
winning whatsoever you know you probably
got participation trophies all
throughout your childhood we ain't out
here getting any trophies with teammates
like this if you are not winning by 14
goals three seconds into a match sit
upside down in the net go drive around
and take all the booster for the rest of
the match and tell everybody in the
lobby that they're [ __ ]
[Music]
clap trash hands
[Music]